Bye.
Paul Cezanne is a painting that dawns on
you at first you see the whole group of
women bathing by a river,
a subject that's anything but original.
The canvas is composed in a balanced
geometry of triangles,
one for the group on the left,
one for those on the right and one
comprising them all bounded by the
leaning trees,
but after a minute,
you start to notice things like the
figures behind the river or the swimmer
in the water,
or almost disturbingly,
that none of the bathers have any
definable faces or that their bodies
seemed to fold into one another as if
they'd been painted over,
but not completely.
The more you stare at it,
the more the canvas seems a chaos of
elements deliriously rendered with the
spontaneity that feels almost negligent.
Of course,
we know that Cezanne labored on this
painting for seven years all the way up
to his death.
Spontaneity is certainly part of the
message,
but the painter was intensely purposeful
in what he wanted to say and how he
wanted to convey it.
From our perspective across the Gulf of
cubism and all imaginable forms of
abstraction,
it's hard for us Cezanne's distortions
of color and form to shock us,
yet that's exactly what they did in 19
Oh,
six.
At the paintings first exhibition.
It's not wrong to say that Cezanne
initiated what became the 20th century's
endless experimentation as Picasso
himself said,
Cezanne is the father of us all in this
way.
He can sort of be seen as the bridge
between what came before and all that
was to come.
The large bathers reaches in the past.
We're calling similar scenes of nudes or
bathers like those by Titian or Nicola
who sewn or Thomas Eakins among others
certain of the figures of vote postures
from older works.
The women on the left striding upwards
with the tree,
for example,
bears a resemblance to an 18th century
sculpture of the goddess Diana,
or take the woman on the right here
who's raised knee and shoulders.
Remember the classical Venus de Milo by
Alexandros of Antioch,
and perhaps it should be noted that none
of the 14 women we see here were drawn
from real models.
Suzanne took his examples from other
works and picture books,
adding to that disquieting sense of
remove that these figures have from any
identifiable personalities that remove
that alienation is echoed everywhere in
the painting of the 14 women,
six or simply turned away from the
viewer,
a few or even in the process of
dissolving or emerging from the foliage.
All around them,
most unsettling have all the figures are
pocked with areas of white,
which on closer examination proves not
to be any paint at all,
but the bare canvas itself interrupting
the scene as if some force from a world
beyond what is Cezanne trying to do
here,
what are these disturbances amount to
what are the effects of his short flat
brush strokes of distilling everything
into its geometrical basis or freezing
in paint that which doesn't appear to be
a scene at all,
but something on the verge of becoming a
scene where else have dissolving out of
one Cezanne is emerging out of
impressionism.
A movement that was obsessed with how
colors and light really appeared to the
eye.
How did the atmosphere,
the rain or the sunset effect the visual
impression of the Observer?
The impressionists explored this by
going out into nature and painting
rapidly applying just what they saw to
the canvas in front of them.
Cezanne took the pallet of the
impressionists,
retaining the brilliant,
often surprising colors used to evoke
nature's effect on us,
but he took color a step further and
applied it to express form as well.
Ever since the renaissance depth was
rendered via perspective.
Cezanne seems to realize that
renaissance perspective is only a kind
of code by which we understand the third
dimension and a canvas seeing itself.
The perception as distinct from the
understanding may not work on those
principles.
It may be far more unruly than that.
This is why he didn't shy away from
distortion of objects of using colors to
bring elements in the background forward
or melt things in the foreground into
the architecture of colors that hold
them there.
There's a difference between the way we
know what we see and how we actually see
it.
Our minds are so incredibly good at
taking the anarchic varieties of
sensible experience and within
milliseconds composing them into
intelligible holes.
It happens so fast that we can't even
access that actual moment of perception
and for the most part we should be happy
about that because raw experience like a
kind of trauma,
it's just too much for us to extend.
In the large bathers.
Cezanne uses his various techniques to
visit that moment of perception,
confronted with it aesthetically.
All that's unsettling about experience
is frozen for our contemplation in life.
It's a bridge we just can't cross and
take a look at that man on the other
side of the river.
Many think that this figure is cezanne
himself situated between the classical
constructed dire ama have bathers and
the pastoral impressionistic church
scene in the distance.
Now I bet if we could turn the painting
around and see it from that perspective,
it would look just as sensual,
erotic and beautiful as something by
Titian or any other painter who depicted
a similar scene in the past,
but from our vantage,
the one Cezanne gave to us,
we're allowed a fugitive access to
something far more disturbing the wheel.
He,
everybody,
if you want to help me keep making these
videos,
I'm doing a big push for patrion
pledges.
Everything helps as little as $1 per
video.
It really is the pledges that allow me
to continue making this channel and you
know,
the more I get,
the more time and effort I can spend on
making really cool stuff and I have a
lot of stuff in the works right now
which is going to be really great if you
think the nerd writer is something that
you're not seeing anywhere else and you
want to see more of it.
I'm pledging is really the way to help
me.
So thank you so much.
And here are some more videos.